Let's take a very simple
robot sensing problem, right?
So let's assume that a robot knows
the 3D map of its world, okay?
And for now,
we're just going to worry about
a robot running around on the floor.
So it's not climbing stairs,
instead it's just running around.
And let's assume also that it
has noisy depth sensors, so
it can measure depth in a lot
of different directions.
And they're noisy, so the,
the measurement is uncertain, but
we know about the uncertainty.
That is we have a sensor model.
Okay?
And it moves between frames, and
it takes a, a set of readings, and
then it moves again and takes a set
of readings, and it moves again.
But the idea is it keeps
taking all these readings, and
the question is,
how well can it know its state?
So, what is its state?
Montana?.
No.
Its state is three values, x,
y and theta, its orientation.
Okay?
That's why we're just doing a,
a multiple robot on
the ground three dimensions.
All right?
So, just to remind you, on a Ba,
Bayesian filter framework,
we need four things.
We need some sort of the prior,
remember that trip to Delphi, so
you unpack your next prior.
We need a dynamical system model and
that's the likelihood of landing in some
new place, given that you're in an old
place plus whatever action was taken.
We need a sensor model, remember,
a likelihood that's the,
not the probability of being
someplace given a measurement.
The likelihood is the probability
of getting the measurement given
what your state was, and then we
need this stream of observations and
the action data, the Zs and the Us.
For that robot that I described,
the state is obvious.
The map will be easy, et cetera.
The thing that's tricky, not tricky,
the thing we have to define,
is the sensor model.
So here's a picture of a sensor model,
and what this is is,
this is the probability of getting
a particular measurement if,
let's say, the actual state was
here on this black line, okay?
And, what was nice is when
your using a real robot,
you can actually measure the likelihood,
so
you, you, you stick the sensor,
you know, three meters away, or,
let's see, it's at centimeters, so 200,
so 2.3 centimeters away from the wall.
You turn it on,
you turn it on, you turn.
You collect a whole bunch of
measurements and you see what you get.
That distribution would
be this distribution.
Okay?
And in fact,
the blue is what was measured.
All right?
So that's why the blue's got
the noisy stuff.
And the red is how they approximated it.
And you can see they basically had
some sort of a Gaussian function or
something like that.
In fact, you can see that the laser
has a less noise than the sonar, okay?
So, this is, this is actually
a relatively noisy laser.
A modern laser would be,
you know, very precise.
Except that you might have some
specular problem, et cetera.
So all of that would be fine, except,
you'll notice there's this thing here
and this thing there, and the question
is, what's going on when, you know,
the thing is 2.3 meters away and
here it says 500.
But, the astute observer will notice
you're just using the very last value.
Well what that really is,
is that's the probability
that you get no return, okay?
So you're some distance from the wall,
you send out your sonar chirp, or
you send out your laser,
and it just goes away.
Gets on a train, never comes back.
This happens you guys know what
specular reflections are, right?
So when light bounces off to,
turns out that sheet rock
is very specular to sonar.
So when you send out a sonar chirp,
often it doesn't come back, it skips
like it reflects off, in which case,
you don't ever hear the chirp come back.
Or it comes back after having
gone through a long echo path.
Likewise, if you're looking at something
that's shiny, like a glass wall.
When you point at it,
you can see the laser beam.
But when you point it on the side, okay?
It'll be reflective.
It'll be a specular.
So what these values are,
is the probability of getting no return
given that you're at some distance.
And in fact, that probability stays
the same pretty much no matter what your
distance is.
All right?
So remember, this is not the probability
that your distance is actually 500.
It's the probability that
you would get this no return
at any given point in time, okay?
So we need to incorporate
that noisy model.